In the video on sp3 hybridized
orbitals, we went in pretty
good detail about how a methane
molecule looks.
But just as a bit of a review,
it's the tetrahedral shape.
You have a carbon in the middle,
and then you would
have a hydrogen-- you can
imagine I'm drawing it like
this because this hydrogen is
poking out of the page.
Then maybe you have another
hydrogen that's in the page.
You have one above the carbon,
and you have one
that's behind the page.
You could imagine it's like a
tripod with a pole sticking
out of the top of the tripod.
Or if you were to imagine the
shape another way, if you were
to connect the hydrogens, you
would have a four-sided
pyramid with a triangle
as each of the sides.
So it would to look something
like this.
I'm trying my best to draw--
the pyramid would look
something like this if you
could see through it.
So this would be one side,
another side would be over
here, and then the backside
would be over here, and then
the fourth side is actually
the side that's
transparent out front.
So the fourth side would be the
actual kind of thing that
we're looking through when
we look at this pyramid.
It would be this front
side right over here.
So you can imagine it different
ways, this was the
case with methane.
Now let's extend this into
a slightly more complex
molecule, and that's ethane.
So the way we've been drawing
it so far-- I guess the
simplest way to draw ethane,
is just like that.
By implication this is ethane.
By implication you have a carbon
there, and a carbon
there, and they'll each have
three hydrogens bonded to it.
And we've drawn it something
like this.
Three hydrogens bonded to
each of these guys.
But now we know that carbon
has these sp3 hybridized
orbitals, that it likes to form
more of a tetrahedral
shape when it bonds.
So an ethane molecule would
actually look more like this.
Let me draw the carbons.
So I'll do the carbons
in orange.
So if that's the carbon
and that's the carbon.
So you can imagine you have
a carbon molecule here.
I'll draw it as this
little circle.
And then if we have some
perspective, so the
carbon-carbon bond is going
to look like that.
And then you have
another carbon
molecule right over there.
So that's that bond over here.
And we want both the carbons,
all of their bonds to be kind
of in a tetrahedral shape.
So then you could imagine
this bond over
here going like this.
This bond going like that.
And you have your hydrogen
at the end.
Let's make the green circles
the hydrogens.
So you have that hydrogen, and
then-- or actually just the
circles, we'll call them
hydrogen-- and then you can
imagine this one, maybe it's
coming out of the page a
little bit.
That is that hydrogen.
Let me label the hydrogens,
actually.
I'm doing it in all different
colors so you can see what I'm
talking about.
And then this hydrogen is going
right below it, maybe
pointed back a little bit.
So that hydrogen is
right over there.
So you can see this carbon,
its bonds have
a tetrahedral shape.
Or, if you just looked at this
part of it, these would be the
base of the tripod and
this would be the
thing sticking up.
Now for this carbon it would
be very similar idea.
This hydrogen right
here, might be
sticking down like this.
And I'll stop switching
colors soon enough.
It takes a lot of time.
That hydrogen over there, it's
pointing out in that
direction like that.
And then you would have,
let's see what
colors do I have left?
Well, I'll just do yellow.
That hydrogen right
there, maybe it's
pointing out like that.
So this is a possible
configuration for ethane.
And the way that I've drawn this
right now, and you can
actually have a model that has
this, where you have little
wooden sticks with balls and
this, the balls to represent
the actual atoms, this is called
a ball and stick model.
And this is a ball and stick
model for ethane.
Now a simpler way we could
have drawn this, this is
called a horse shoe projection--
or actually it's
a sawhorse production.
I always say horse shoe.
A sawhorse projection.
It would look like this.
This exact same configuration
of ethane in a sawhorse
projection.
And you know what a sawhorse
looks like, well, it looks
like what I'm about to draw.
It looks like this.
So you could, well I could
draw it exactly the
way I drew it here.
So you have the carbon, carbon,
and then you have the
hydrogen, hydrogen, hydrogen,
and then you have a-- well,
the way I've drawn it up
here is more like this.
Just so we see the parallel
and then we can
rotate things around.
The way I drew it up here,
you have a hydrogen,
hydrogen, and hydrogen.
And then over here you
have a hydrogen,
hydrogen, and hydrogen.
This is a sawhorse projection.
Now, either way you depict
it, I mean, these are
really the same way.
This is kind of just like
the lazier way of
doing it on some level.
You're not drawing all of these
circles and all of that,
and you're putting a little
less care into actually
showing the angle, how things
are angled away from the
carbon and showing the
tetrahedral shape.
But in either case, when you
start visualizing the molecule
in this way, you start to
realize there's, well, there's
actually infinite ways that
these things can be
configured.
And it all comes from the notion
that this is just a
sigma bond right here.
We learned that in the video on
sp3 hybridization and sigma
and pi bonds.
This is just a sigma bond.
And so we can rotate
around the bonds.
One of these carbons could
rotate around the axis of that
bond without the other
carbon having to
necessarily rotate with it.
If this was a double bond, if
this was a pi bond, they would
have to rotate together.
So you could have a situation
like I've drawn here or you
could have a situation where
they're kind of rotated the
inverse of each other.
And this is what I mean.
So I'll do a ball and stick.
So let's say this is our front
carbon, that is our back
carbon, and we'll compare it
to this one over here.
So let me draw this guy
the exact same way.
So he's got a hydrogen down
here, he's got a hydrogen up
there, and then he's got
a hydrogen up here.
So that part of the ethane
looks identical.
Now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to flip the other
side of the ethane.
I want you to pay close
attention, because hopefully
you'll see the difference
between the two.
So instead of doing this blue
ethane down here-- this blue
hydrogen down here-- I'm
going to do it on top.
So this blue one, I want to
do that in blue, this blue
hydrogen, put it on top.
So I'm just rotating
this around.
So the blue hydrogen's on top.
So I've rotated it so the
blue one's on top now.
And now the green one is
going to go over here.
So now the green hydrogen
is now over here.
And then this purple, or this
magenta hydrogen, the way I've
rotated it, is now going
to go over here.
So what's the difference between
this configuration and
this configuration right here?
And we could have
had every other
configuration in between.
But what's the real
difference here?
Well, here the hydrogen, you
could imagine that hydrogen is
kind of, if you were looking
from that direction, that
hydrogen is directly behind that
hydrogen, that hydrogen
is directly behind that
hydrogen, that hydrogen is
directly behind that.
This is called an eclipsed
configuration, or eclipsed
conformation.
So eclipsed conformation.
And this right here, nothing
is behind anything.
If you went straight
back from this guy,
you'd get to this point.
And no one's behind it.
And if you went straight forward
from this guy you'll
get-- So in no way are any of
the guys in the back-- once
again, if your viewing from
this direction-- are they
blocked by any of
the people here.
So we call this a staggered
conformation.
Now, why do we even care?
OK, I can twist around
this back molecule.
What's that even going to do for
our actual-- why does it
even matter?
Well, one, it's just interesting
that you can
actually change, that this thing
can twist around without
changing the front-- without the
front molecule having to
twist with it.
But even more important, these
have different energy levels,
so you can kind of think of
them as you're kind of
twisting a spring and the spring
might want to go back
to one conformation
or another.
And to visualize it a little
better, I'll draw what's
called a Newman Projection.
So I'm going to draw this exact
thing, but with a Newman
Projection, you draw the carbon
molecules directly in
front or directly behind
each other.
So in this situation, you would
draw the carbon molecule
in front, would just be the
intersection of these bonds.
So for a Newman Projection--
let me draw that out.
So it's a Newman Projection and
I'll start with the Newman
Projection for the staggered
conformation.
So in the front-- we'll consider
this carbon the front
carbon-- we have our
hydrogen pointing
straight down like that.
And we have a hydrogen
coming out to the
top left, like that.
And then we have this
hydrogen over here
coming up to the right.
I want to do that in
that same color.
So the front carbon is
implicitly at the intersection
of the bonds of these
three hydrogens.
And then the back carbon-- I
said the front carbon is the
intersection of the bonds of
these three hydrogens-- the
back carbon you represented
as a circle.
So the circle represents
the back of carbon.
The front carbon is kind
of that point there.
This is a way of
visualizing it.
But if we were to draw it this
way, the back carbon now has
that blue hydrogen popping
off of it.
So it has that blue hydrogen,
this green hydrogen, and then
this magenta hydrogen.
And when you look at it like
this, it is more clear that
it's staggered.
We're just looking straight on
to this ethane molecule.
When we look straight on, the
front carbon, they're
obviously blocking each other.
But this way you can see the
front carbon's hydrogens are
staggered relative
to the back ones.
So this is right here, once
again, this is staggered.
Now let's draw the eclipsed
conformation as a Newman
Projection.
So as a Newman Projection
the front's
going to look the same.
You have a hydrogen there, you
have this hydrogen, you have
that hydrogen, and then you
have that blue, or I guess
that purple hydrogen,
down here.
So that's the front of it.
But the back, they're
right behind it's.
So let me draw the
back carbon.
The front carbon is kind of
represented by just that dot.
The back carbon we'll
represent like that.
And the staggered conformation,
if this guy's
really behind that, you're going
to have to draw it like,
right there, like
right behind it.
But since that's a little bit
messy, normally when people
draw a staggered projection-- an
eclipsed conformation, as a
Newman Projection.
Instead of directly eclipsing
that last, that back hydrogen,
they'll put it to the right a
little, or they'll push it off
a little bit.
So that's that hydrogen.
That magenta hydrogen
is right there.
It's really right behind the
front one, but this is just so
you can actually see
that it's there.
And then finally you have this
blue one down there.
So that blue one is going
to be right over here.
So this is the eclipsed
conformation as a Newman
Projection.
And as you can see,
it's eclipsed.
The back hydrogens are eclipsed
by the front ones.
If I were to draw it perfectly,
they would be
right behind it.
Now there's one other piece of,
I guess one more idea, I
want to introduce you to, and
that's the notion of the angle
between the different
hydrogens.
So if you wanted to say, well,
what is this angle?
What is this angle between the
blue hydrogen and this pink
hydrogen right here?
Now, when you actually think
of it in three dimensions,
it's like, wow, you can't really
say the angle over here
between blue and the pink.
But on a Newman Projection, when
you're just saying how
much are they rotated away from
each other, this angle
right here is called
a dihedral angle.
Sometimes it's just said, you
know, this hydrogen relative
to that hydrogen has a DA of,
in this case, 60 degrees.
In this case, this hydrogen
relative to that hydrogen has
a dihedral angle of
zero degrees.
And it's a way of saying,
how staggered, or how
eclipsed, you are.
Now, one last thing I touched on
the idea, so again, why do
we even care?
Well, all of these hydrogens
have electron clouds around
them, and all of these
bonds have electron
clouds around them.
And electron clouds, they're all
negative, so they want to
get as far away from each
other as possible.
And they're all stable now,
because they've bonded in ways
that they have nice
stable structures.
Everyone feels like they
have full valence
shells, full orbitals.
And so the electron
clouds want to get
away from each other.
Now in this situation, in the
eclipsed conformation, this
hydrogen and this hydrogen--
let me do it in-- this
hydrogen and this hydrogen are
closer to each other than when
you go to the staggered
conformation.
The staggered conformation, the
closest hydrogen to this
guy is going to be either that
hydrogen or that hydrogen.
But they're both further away
than this hydrogen was in the
eclipsed conformation.
So in general, the staggered
conformation is going to be
more stable.
It's going to have a lower
potential energy.
You can imagine that if you
start with an eclipsed
conformation, these guys are all
going to want to get away
from each other.
So it's kind of like this is
the wound conformation.
It has higher potential
energy.
So it'll want to unwind and
it'll want to unwind to a
staggered conformation, because
in this conformation,
all of the hydrogens
have gotten as far
away from each other.